the [ __ ] hey what is going on your
[ __ ] Chinese finger traps but now I
said I'd do these videos more often and
to be honest with you if you guys have
more topics and more questions I could
do as much as these videos as you want
because it's kind of easy for me and
it's entertaining for you so you know
just [ __ ] start asking questions you
but recently a subscriber asked how do
you deal with haters because I feel like
all my haters are always weighing down
on me this is the [ __ ] funny now I
think because I'm a very intelligent man
her I hate her as somebody that for no
[ __ ] apparent reason just hates you
damn guts like it's because you're
successful you're doing fine or
something but every time you do well
this person just hates you right now I
think in the past I did do a video on
this type of [ __ ] but let me just get
into the nitty-gritty of things a lot of
the times when people say that they have
haters the first thing that I want to
ask them is this [ __ ] are you and this
isn't just to YouTube this is to me too
when I say I have haters I really have
to think to myself David oh [ __ ] are you
you right now think that you are so
[ __ ] important that people are just
sitting at home just preying on your
downfall which by far is like the
douchiest thing to say or feel about
yourself you know what I'm saying people
out here they praying on my downfall
anyoneís tweak out of here bro you ain't
not that [ __ ] important the fact that
you actually think when you walk in a
room you are so [ __ ] dope people are
like oh Jessie I'm gonna get in that
corner mother pray to Jesus all these
[ __ ] down box yeah God please
let this [ __ ] dick explode
please just let it explode do you know
these type of people the INA kid you not
these are the type of human beings that
if they could suck their own dick they
would these by the way are the same type
of people too
that got like 50 followers on Instagram
and they do Instagram life stories and
they start doing polls and [ __ ] hey guys
I know you guys have been curious so
just ask me a question nobody is curious
[ __ ] ask you a question you jackass
there's only 70 people out there man we
know you in fact during your Instagram
live take you can probably say all of
our names within
11 second bar what are you gonna tell me
oh I just want to feel important you
want to feel important you are important
it doesn't work with Instagram okay your
importance as a human being is not gonna
be dependent on an app and what random
people say or feel about you you want to
feel important that's something that you
have to work on on your own time so
don't give me that [ __ ] [ __ ]
about oh boy well well well you just
know me me ain't hatin on you I don't
like you enough to hate on you I don't
care about you enough to hate on you and
in fact if you went across the street
right now and a [ __ ] Sphinx came down
picks you up and ate your ass and [ __ ]
you out into a [ __ ] oversized toilet
I still would not give a [ __ ] I wouldn't
even lift my phone just to do it for the
gram that's how little I care about you
and that's how little most people do I'm
not talking about the people important
in life I'm talking about strangers so
if you're out there right now when you
think that these quote-unquote haters
are preying on your downfall
maybe you're the douchebag but on the
other hand if you are doing something
right you are a hard worker you are
doing whatever you're doing and there
are just people out that they just hate
to see you smile that might be a
different situation that just might mean
you have some [ __ ] toxic ass people
in your life those people are probably
haters and the reason why a lot of
people tend to want to bring you down is
because they don't feel good about
themselves these are just [ __ ] facts
if you have these type of friends in
your life right now that have to drag
you down to keep them at the same level
that they are in order for them to be
happy you got a really really with the
people you're kicking it with right well
my friends are successful I'm probably
more happy for them than they are than I
am for myself do you guys see me on the
hike man dude when I see my friends
succeed I'm that dude aside oh well
you've got their new shoes who let you
pick your nose cut it if you are that
person out there that have a group of
friends that aren't doing that for you
you know you might you might be in the
wrong group like I'm not saying that
these people have to be high 24/7 like
me but people should be generally happy
for your success if they are important
people in your lives now mind you if
you're talking about
once again you're just sitting here and
some people are making a few comments in
your life [ __ ] I'm tight
these dead ages haters you a [ __ ]
loser shut the [ __ ] up you that you got
an Instagram live homie which I know who
bro you know who you are I think these
dudes ask questions like hey what should
I eat today nobody [ __ ] cares what
food you eat [ __ ]
we try to figure out what we try to eat
for lunch like I'm sitting here worried
about the food that's gonna go in your
stomach and come out your ass holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] blueberries are strong
baby cares I kid you not if any of you
out there end up being like a really
close friend of mine and you started
doing this [ __ ] and trust me my
friends roast me all the time I'm
literally gonna be in that [ __ ] chat
with the to other people and say lose my
[ __ ] number
by the way when I tell somebody that
they're not [ __ ] it doesn't mean that
you're not an important person then it
doesn't mean that you're not important
to somebody out there what I mean is
[ __ ] humble yourself you are stressing
about people who don't like you who the
[ __ ] cares and even if they didn't I
guarantee you they're not thinking about
you as much as you are thinking about
them and if that's the [ __ ] case
they're [ __ ] winning they've affected
you so much that all you're doing is
walking around with the [ __ ] douche
tag on your face can't nothin y'all
cannot my hustle [ __ ] imma keep
grindin nobody asked you [ __ ] nobody
alright
I don't even pray for myself and nobody
gonna pray on your downfall [ __ ] I need
a new bicycle on you have never ridden a
bike in [ __ ] years and [ __ ] man I
miss that stuff a little bell and [ __ ]
you know ting ting ting alright
everybody if you guys want to see more
content from me you know do the doing
these like advice [ __ ] what happened
here one my pet run off if you guys want
to see more content where I'm just
blogging giving you guys advice or
anything is on my mind let me know man
you know I'm here for you these videos
don't take too long it takes like an
hour to edit I've got you man let's
let's reconnect let's do this [ __ ] I do
like doing this or sometimes I gets a
little busy sometimes I just don't know
what to say love you [ __ ]